video game publishes it is time to stop
kidding yourselves you're probably not
going to make the next Destiny and your
repeated attempts to is hurting the
industry this week on spot on we are
talking about why every game is
basically Destiny now or at least has
some elements of games as a service
whether we like it or not and why are we
talking about this time this week was
the launch of a little game called
redfall which comes to us from Arcane
Studios storied and beloved developer
Austin Studios known for prey it is
known for immersive Sims but it comes
from a overall company that also has
given us death Loop Dishonored
Dishonored 2 the DLCs around them death
of the outsider and I've done all
amazing games and redfall is in fact
quite different from something that
would that they would make it is more
closer to something like Destiny it's
got a lot of the elements of a games as
a service lifestyle game including you
know the loot issue element the tiered
loot the weird cursor thing that
everyone seems to do I feel like Destiny
is to blame for that weird cursing fine
on PC but on Console it's taken me
probably since 20 yeah I don't like it
when you play the game it feels like
those elements of the games as a service
that are standardized at this point in a
lot of games are actively clashing with
the design that we know Arcane is known
for we're not saying that Arcane can't
make another game it just feels like
this was an immersive Sim with more
ambition and open world and then
suddenly a games as a service title
obviously it's happened with redfold
which comes from a studio it is very
close to uh both of our hearts we love
and immersive Sim but it is kind of
indicative of the the way the industry
has certainly been changing games as a
service those elements existed before
Destiny but now everything is really
trying to ape the destiny model with uh
limited uh success I would say almost
no success in for the most part
obviously we've seen this before with
Warcraft clones but now it's Destiny's
time uh because like trying to be
Destiny like is certainly a trend it's
very in Vogue has been for the past few
years
um but chasing Trends especially in game
development where things take so long
projects take years to come to fruition
it's almost always a Fool's errand the
first thing is what you just said like
it takes a really long time to make a
game like Destiny and not just that it
takes probably equal amount of time or
more to get it into a place where it's
good like Destiny for example came out
and people who are around at that time
will remember it wasn't great for 10
gamespot.com yeah exactly it took a year
after Destiny came out for it to start
to get good and that was the release of
the taken King from that point on people
started treating it as a real kind of
like this has got potential people would
argue that it still didn't get amazing
until Destiny 2 2 at which point it's
still a constant push and pull struggle
between is it good is it bad every new
update changes that conversation in a
significant way it's definitely this
Urban Flow of success with these
lifestyle games you have to have that
dedicated audience who are going to be
with you through thick and thin games
that are now coming out in the wake of
Destiny trying to be Destiny they are
naturally behind the Trends they are
lagging in terms of a lot of design
ideas kind of like developments in the
industry and also the sentiment around
games as a service with the audience
like you might start making a games as a
service now and by the time it's out
people hate that chances are if you're
making a destiny like or a games service
title is a pretty good chance that
you're already outdated these games that
are being developed as Destiny style or
like games as a service style games they
are arriving in a kind of genre and a
space within the industry that is
dominated by Major players there's not a
lot of air these are experiences that
have been polished over years they're
not just coming out and rough now
they've been almost perfected to a
degree and the reason that is important
is because there was a phase in
development or in the games as a service
model where mistakes were okay people
were more willing to accept it because
there's new territory everyone was
failing in some regard and iterating and
figuring it out we are way past that
phase well the thing is now is that if
there is something going maybe a season
in Apex is not what I would really enjoy
we'll watch to stop me hopping back to
OverWatch it's also a cost Factor too
right maybe you don't want to buy the
latest expansion the way I think of it
is either it needs to iterate evolve or
innovate is your games as a service
doing one of those because that's the
only way you can exist in a genre that
has its Titans and and sadly for redfall
you know they had those ideas
implemented and sadly not well the fact
that only the host carries on
progression for example seems pretty
obvious but the reason why a lot of the
times uh Publishers and developers are
chasing the games as a service Destiny
like trend is because it brings in a ton
of money video game development
exceedingly exceedingly expensive and so
why make a bunch of games that people
might buy for 60 70 Play Once trade in
when you can make one box product
release extra content down the line
where people are going to pay more money
for that's a major part of it and you
know we had this period where
pre-owned and secondhand games were
genuinely a problem it was oh remember
the EA's um online passing yeah all this
kind of stuff the Cerberus Network there
were so many solutions that didn't work
to try and curtail that kind of I bought
the game for you now I'm gonna a week
later pay let GameStop take all the
profits from there or whatever retailer
is so that's a big part of it but also
it's just on the one hand we are buying
a game that is purely digital so all the
money goes to the Publishers and
developers Publishers mostly and then
all the content delivered on that is
digital on top of that people are not
able to buy games that expensive 78 at a
rate that they used to be one game to
rule them all is what you want and then
on top of that it fits into this
lifestyle that we have now you know we
open an app and we watch a series we
open YouTube we watch a bunch of videos
when it comes to games you want people
to think of it as an ecosystem and a
world you keep coming back to and the
upside of that is if you can nail it
he's huge people are basically building
a habit of being in your game which
means when you make small changes when
you make additional content that you can
pay for or if you have hooks in there
like microtransactions they're way more
likely to pay into it and have that
ecosystem kind of Thrive the thing about
it is and the reason why we're saying
you got to stop doing this is because
that is very rare exceedingly rare
you're more likely to hit the worst case
scenario it's forcing talented
developers who are known for certain
things to step out of their comfort zone
in a way that feels forced I'm not
advocating for Never Letting developers
do anything else I tweeted about this I
think Arcane is capable of making any
game the difference is is are they
making that game on their own terms
Avengers is the perfect example Crystal
Dynamics is known for single player
story-driven campaigns the best part of
Avengers is the Kamala Khan campaign
that was the thing that we were all
going around being like the campaign's
really good people should play this the
game is a service title part of it was
not good I can't even tell you if
Spider-Man is out yet is he out who
knows I played that game intensely for
ages released in 2021
well no one cares Gotham Knights is
another example of what happens when it
feels forced all the stuff that I liked
about Gotham Knights is the same stuff I
liked about Arkham Origins all
undermined by the games as a service
stuff and it's why people are so
concerned about suicide squad which is
you know a game that we haven't really
heard that much of an in-depth look at
other than hey shoot the purple stuff
for massive damage I am a huge fan of
Brock's daddy like a huge fan of
Rocksteady a huge fan of Batman a huge
fan of the DC stuff around that when
they revealed the games as a service
element of this I cannot tell you how
deflated I felt and I I know for a fact
everyone else is exactly the same we've
been waiting so long for this and I now
we have this this it feels invasive
these games feel invasive now where it's
like you're not gonna play this you need
to commit forever to this if you are
trying to make an ambitious Destiny
Style game because it's the trend
chances are the trend that you will
actually hit is the one of failure that
was the first episode of spot on every
week Tam and I are going to be tackling
another hard-hitting industry topic so
we hope you'll join us here every Friday
we don't want to end all doom and gloom
this week wanted to highlight the fact
that it is Ludo narakon over on Steam it
is the festival's fifth year basically a
celebration of narrative driven games
there is like 35 demos there are a bunch
of really cool talks if you're on
Gamespot this week you'll see we've
launched a whole bunch of new shows so
please go check those out tomorrow we're
gonna have firearms expert reacts and
Sunday we'll have Dave Klein doing how
it's saved with Resident Evil 4. so it's
a big it's been a big week huge huge
week and thank you so much for watching
you want to get a whale yeah you want a
whale oh you want some
minnows who will